[Musique]
quatre mois après le chat cash de l'arc
de triomphe et les champs elysées sont
en ruine la france veut propager l'image
de la paix en afrique enchérit mais il
est incapable de l'assuré au parisien à
quelques encablures de l'elysée alors ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur donc quel délai vous vous
engager vis-à-vis de vos hommes
vis-à-vis des parisiens vis-à-vis des
franches et à rétablir l'ordre
samedi dernier il y a eu un vrai
dysfonctionnement car cette doctrine
réactive d'interpellations elle n'a pas
été mise en ordre en oeuvre pardon alors
même que nous avions donné des
instructions extrêmement précises avec
christophe castaner en ce sens et c'est
ce qui nous a conduit à renforcer encore
plus sa doctrine et comme vous le savez
le premier ministre a annoncé désormais
tout attroupement qui risquent de
présenter un caractère volent violent
sera immédiatement dispersés et seront
prises à l'appui de ces mesures
des arrêtés d'interdiction qui seront
conclus avec chacun des maires concernés
et qui permettront de venir appuyer ces
mesures de dispersion d'attroupement
mais permettez moi d'insister vous le
savez très bien monsieur le sénateur
philippe dominati vous savez très bien
qu'à paris des débordements matière
d'ordre public il y en a eu plein
d'autres et sous d'autres quinquennat le
fait mais sczesny neige que vous me
répondiez vous attire la sympathie de
cet hémicycle
car nous avons tous compris que vous
étiez le prochain fusible ma question
s'adresser au ministre de l'intérieur
en décidant d'appeler les militaires
vous prenez une très grande
responsabilité
vous devez expliquer aux français dans
quel cadre vous plantez employés des
militaires quelles consignes leur ont
été données seront ils autorisés à le
faire usage de leurs armes en cas de
débordements kelly cette distinction est
faite entre délinquants eni nous avons
besoin d'éclaircissements suite aux
déclarations contradictoires de vos
ministres retirer des militaires de
l'opération sentinelles pour les mettre
sur le maintien de l'ordre c'est aussi
affaiblir la sécurité des français dans
les gares dans les aéroports sur les
marchés face à la menace terroriste
vous exposez enfin bruno militaire vous
prenez le risque de déstabiliser une
institution qui est mobilisé et dédiée
depuis 2015 à la lutte contre le
terrorisme
voulez vous réellement prendre le risque
d'affaiblir les militaires ont les
embarquant dans une polémique
s'il devait y avoir des blessés par
balles voire pire
il est bien évidemment pas question que
les maudites les militaires de
sentinelle soit à la fois détournés de
leur fonction qui est celle de dans le
cadre de sentinelle de protéger les
français du risque terroriste de
protéger les français face à des tueries
de masse est d'être présent partout
partout en france et dans paris en
particulier il n'est pas question
d'utiliser les forces armées les
militaires pour gérer l'ordre public
tout simplement parce que et vous l'avez
dit dans votre question et vous avez une
expérience de ministre au ministère des
armées vous le savez ils ont de très
grandes qualités mais ils ne sont pas
formés ni équipés pour gérer leur gérer
l'ordre public et donc samedi prochain
comme pour les samedis passé depuis le
mouvement le début du mouvement des
gilet jaune
mais comme depuis 2015 les militaires de
sentinelle seront là pour épauler les
français dans l'enjeu de sécurité ils
seront là pour épauler aussi nos forces
de sécurité sur ces sujets là mais pas
pour gérer l'ordre public
à certains endroits ils se substitueront
ils se substitueront pour garder des
bâtiments qui ne seront pas exposés à un
risque de manifestations
ils se substitueront pour libérer des
forces qui elles seront des forces de
police ou de gendarmes qui elles seront
mobilisés pour assurer la gestion de
l'ordre public
parent